keine opfer bei iranischen raketen-
beschuss auf us-truppen trump verzichtet
auf einen gegenschlag der iran hatte
rechtzeitig gewarnt flugzeugunglück nahe
teheran 176 menschen sterben kurz nach
dem start der ukrainischen maschine
neues im falle der hauptverdächtige
stefan beschuldigt nun einen komplizen
den kasseler regierungspräsidenten
erschossen zu haben
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abends willkommen an
diesem mittwoch dem 8 januar mit dabei
für den sport norbert lehmann ein schön
kolander formiert nicht mal eine woche
hat es gedauert bis der iran auf die
tötung von general sulimani durch die
amerikaner antwortete in der nacht holte
er zum gegenschlag aus und beschoss zwei
us stützpunkten im irak mit raketen
am nachmittag trat us-präsident trump
vor die presse kündigte aber lediglich
weitere wirtschaftssanktionen für den
iran an
david sauer zeigt uns die geschehnisse
der nacht wenige stunden erst ist der
von den usa getötete general zu lehman
ii unter der erde
als irans vergeltungsaktion startet kurz
nach mitternacht unserer zeit steigen
die iranischen raketen in den himmel auf
ihr erstes ziel einen
us-luftwaffenstützpunkt westlich von
bagdad im zentrum des irak die al assad
rbs diese handy bilder sollen die
einschläge zeigen
das zweite ziel ist eine militärbasis
bei r bild die die usa nutzen die
raketen erreichen das lager aber
offenbar nicht mehr als 110
bundeswehrsoldaten bilden dort irakische
einheiten aus sie alle sind wohlauf
sofort gibt es eine krisensitzung im
weißen haus die usa sagen es gebe keine
opfer alles ist gut schreibt präsident
trump auf twitter irans staatsfernsehen
hingegen behauptet 80 amerikanische
terroristen seien getötet worden
das ist ein schlag ins gesicht unseres
feindes amerika sagte ayatollah khamenei
als vergeltung aber seien solche
aktionen nicht ausreichend damit ist
eingetreten was alle welt befürchtete
theoretisch könnte nun eine spirale der
gewalt entstehen die sich kaum noch
stoppen lässt allerdings lassen der
relativ maßvolle angriff des iran und
die ebenso maßvolle reaktion des
us-präsidenten heute nachmittag hoffen
dass es nicht so kommt ines trams blickt
in den iran und analysiert trumps worte
vizepräsident außen und
verteidigungsminister die generäle sie
kommen zuerst ein signal der stärke
doch nachdem dutzende iranische raketen
us militärstützpunkte im irak trafen sie
präsident trump von militärischer
vergeltung ab schließlich hätte es keine
todesopfer
nur geringen schaden gegeben es scheint
so dass der iran zurück weicht und das
ist eine gute sache für alle beteiligten
und für die welt die usa wollten ihre
militärische stärke nicht anwenden es
bleibt aber die forderung der iran müsse
sein nuklearprogramm und den terror
hinter sich lassen
die usa werden sofort zusätzliche
wirtschaftssanktionen gegenüber dem
iranischen regime verhängen diese
kraftvollen sanktionen bleiben in kraft
bis der iran sein verhalten ändert
tramper greift nun die option die gewalt
spirale zu stoppen trotz allen
säbelrasseln schlugen die iraner nicht
mit voller wucht zu sie hätten
amerikanische ziele noch viel härter
treffen können
die iraner hätten den einsatz ganz
anders erhöhen können ich denke sie
wollten eine botschaft senden nicht aber
substanzielle rache üben
nach der tötung seines generals sulimani
will der iran so scheint es eine
deeskalation nun ermöglichen der
außenminister spricht von einem
verhältnismäßigen abgeschlossenen
angriff wir haben diesen prozess der
eskalation nicht begonnen die usa führen
einen wirtschaftlichen krieg gegen uns
die usa müssen zur vernunft kommen sie
sollten aufhören auf clown zu hören
ein moment von krieg und frieden
präsident trump verzichtet auf einen
militärschlag doch der konflikt zwischen
iran und usa ist längst nicht gelöst
erreicht ist nur eine atempause
ja die sorge vor einem möglichen krieg
ist also groß fragen wir unsere
korrespondenten in den usa und in
teheran zuerst nach washington zur mrt
wissen wir haben trump gerade gehört der
sich offenbar in zurückhaltung übt und
dem iran lediglich wirtschaftssanktionen
an droht ein gutes signal
ja das ist dass ich glaube donald trump
hat gewissermaßen die letzte ausfahrt
vor dem großen krieg genommen und hofft
dass die iran oder mitziehen das ist für
ihn innenpolitisch wichtig weil er hat
immer versprochen amerikas kriegen
herauszuholen nicht einen neuen krieg zu
beginnen also das ist gut für ihn den
wahlkampf er kann für sich verbuchen
dass er stärke gezeigt hat er hat auch
einen wichtigen terroranführer
ausgeschaltet durch diese gezielte
tötung von sulimani aber man muss auch
klar sagen dass die usa strategisch
einen hohen preis dafür zahlen
indem sie ihre eigene position im irak
massiv geschwächt haben da wird der
einfluss des iran größer und sicherlich
auch dadurch dass im iran das regime
selbst gestärkt ist und obendrein das
für amerikanische soldaten und
amerikanische staatsbürger rund um den
erdball nicht sicherer geworden ist weil
es könnte ja immer noch racheakt für die
tötung silly moniz geben wenn es in der
vergangenen nacht beispielsweise
todesopfer gegeben hätte dann wäre diese
deeskalation heute sicher nicht möglich
von washington nach teheran zu ja brase
jörg auch sie haben trump zugehört der
offenbar keine größere gewalt mehr vom
iran befürchtet liegt er damit richtig
also zumindest was diesen
vergeltungsschlag angeht glaube ich
liegt er da richtig denn in der tat die
iranische seite hatte im moment
jedenfalls kein interesse daran diesen
konflikt zu eskalieren
dieser gegenschlag viel doch moderater
aus als gedacht und erfolgte mit
vorwarnung die irakische seite hat
bestätigt dass sie kurz nach mitternacht
aus iran hinweise bekommen hat dass ein
angriff unmittelbar bevorsteht auffällig
ist auch dass die iranische führung die
er sonst auch sehr gerne twittert sich
bis jetzt jedenfalls komplett zurück
hält mit kommentaren zur rede von donald
trump ob sich der teil der bevölkerung
der in den vergangenen tagen mit lauten
tod den usa rufen hier auf der straße
gezeigt hat ob auch der teil sich mit
diesem vergeltungsschlag zufrieden zeigt
das muss man sehen ich glaube aber schon
die menschen mit denen wir heute hier
gesprochen haben sagten uns alle dass
sie angst haben vor einem krieg mit den
usa
und die werden jetzt alle sehr
erleichtert sein dass ein
eskalation offenbar bis jetzt jedenfalls
verhindert werden konnte herzlichen dank
für ihre analyse jörg brase und elmar
theveßen
trotz dieser ermutigenden signale die
welt hält weiter den atem an
der iranische raketen angriff wird von
den meisten regierungen verurteilt
denn die sorge vor einem krieg am golf
ist nach wie vor groß deutschland warnt
vor einer weiteren eskalation und auch
die eu befindet sich im krisenmodus
christoph festival
brüssel 8 uhr morgens früh wie selten
tag die eu-kommission auch weil die
chefin dringende termine hat vor allem
aber zeigen will wie ernst man die krise
am golf nimmt sie fordert waffen müssten
jetzt schweigen höchste zeit für dialog
wir alle müssen alles geben damit wieder
geredet wird und helfen um die lage zu
deeskalieren da hat die eu in der region
jede menge zu bieten
auch in brüssel und auch mindestens
besorgt verteidigungsminister maß wir
verurteilen diesen angriff und jeder
sollte seinen beitrag dazu leisten dass
jetzt zurückhaltung geübt wird dass sich
die lage beruhigt immerhin hätten die
raketen auf erbil auch deutsche soldaten
treffen können rund 110 sind dort noch
doch das verteidigungsministerium
beruhigt allesamt wohlauf
nicht zuletzt dank vorwarnung mehr als
50 kilometer kam wohl keine der raketen
ran ans lager trotzdem bedenklich wir
sind derzeit auch in prüfungen über
einen möglichen teilrückzug aus mehr
oder weniger raus aus dem irak das sei
keine politische entscheidung nichts
endgültiges betont berlin
deutschland stehe zu seinem engagement
dort gerade zum gemeinsamen kampf gegen
den selbsternannten islamischen staat
aber man müsse eben sehen was kommt
weitere analysen der angespannten lage
am persischen golf sehen sie auch in
einem zdf spezial gleich im anschluss an
diese sendung und hintergründe wer sich
im mittleren osten nun wie positioniert
finden sie im internet unter heute.de
und inmitten aller politischen und milli
tierischen querelen in iran kam von dort
in der nacht eine weitere schockierende
nachricht ein ukrainischer passagierjet
ist abgestürzt alle 176 menschen an bord
starben
die boeing 737 800 der ukrainian
international air lines war südlich von
teheran auf dem internationalen
flughafen gestartet
nach wenigen minuten brach im steigflug
der funkkontakt ab an der absturzstelle
etwas weiter nördlich wurden zwischen
den trümmern mittlerweile die beiden
flugschreiber gefunden
kristiansand berichtet ein feuerball ist
entfernt am nachthimmel dieses
amateurvideo soll die brennende
ukrainische maschine zeigen die letzten
sekunden in der luft dann der aufprall
die trümmer an der absturzstelle
verteilt über ein feld in der nähe der
hauptstadt teheran
helfer bergen die leichen sammeln die
persönlichen gegenstände der getöteten
passagiere ein
das abgestürzte flugzeug ist 500 meter
bei den boden geschlittert zum glück ist
es nicht über bewohntem gebiet
abgestürzt die boeing 737 800 der
ukrainian international airlines war
unterwegs von teheran nach kiew heute
morgen zwei minuten nach dem start
stürzte die maschine ab
ein unglück oder doch einen
raketenbeschuss ein ganz wichtiges indiz
was gegen einen raketen bei
andersgeartete angriff spricht ist im
prinzip die sehr geringe fläche über die
trümmer verteilt liegen bei einem
angriff ist zu vermuten dass die
maschine in der luft auseinander brechen
würde und dabei sehr viel größeren raum
verteilt eine fläche verteilt immer
sehen können dass hier nicht der fall
an bord waren 176 menschen niemand
überlebte nach ukrainischen angaben
kommen die meisten opfer aus dem iran
und aus kanada
trauer auch in kiew valérie marktkauf
ist zum flughafen gekommen sein sohn
igor war als flugbegleiter auf maschine
ps 07 52
meine tochter rief an und fragte wo igor
gerade fliegt und wir sagten teheran
und dass er mit der früh maschine zurück
kommt
dann sahen wir die bilder vom
flugzeugabsturz erst vor zwei tagen war
der unglücksflieger durchgecheckt worden
es war eine unserer besten maschinen
betont die fluggesellschaft die ukraine
schickt nun ein eigenes ermittlungsteam
in den iran russland und die türkei in
libyen unterstützen sie die
gegensätzlichen parteien im bürgerkrieg
jetzt der gemeinsame aufruf zur
beruhigung der lage
die präsidenten beider länder putin und
erdogan forderten nach einem fordern
nach einem treffen in istanbul eine
waffenruhe
sie soll in der nacht zum sonntag in
kraft treten überraschende neuigkeiten
im mordfall walter lübke
der mutmaßliche täter stephanie
bestreitet nun den kasseler
regierungspräsidenten erschossen zu
haben
es sei ein komplize gewesen und der
schuss habe sich versehentlich gelöst
anfang juni wurde lübke auf seiner
terrasse getötet durch einen kopfschuss
aus nächster nähe
zwei wochen später konnte stephanie
festgenommen werden aufgrund einer
dna-spur die tat hat zu einer neuen
debatte um rechtsextreme gewalt geführt
dominik löschmeister mehrere stunden
dauert die befragung von stephanie durch
ermittlungsrichter des
bundesgerichtshofs heute in kassel
stephanie ändert darin seine aussage
bestreitet nun den tödlichen schuss auf
den kasseler regierungspräsidenten
abgegeben zu haben belastet seinen
mutmaßlichen komplizen marcus h hier im
vordergrund
der anwalt von stefan erklärt beide
tatverdächtigen wären am tatort gewesen
im zuge dieses gesprächs der später
getötete doktor lübke aufgestanden sein
und versucht haben nach hilfe zu rufen
und daraufhin hätte sich aus der waffe
die der hartmann auf den herrn doktor
lübke gerichtet hat ein schuss gelöst
weiter lübke war anfang juni 2009 10 auf
der terrasse seines wohnhauses mit einem
kopfschuss getötet worden
die ermittler fanden an der kleidung
lüpkes die dna von stephanie der nun
bezichtigte markus haar sitzt ebenso wie
ein weiterer verdächtiger wegen beihilfe
zum mord in untersuchungshaft er soll
die tatwaffe vermittelt haben
stephanie hatte den mord und den
regierungspräsidenten zuerst gestanden
dann widerrufen ein wilder geständnis
wandel vom einzeltäter zu mann der nur
dabei stand als ich aus versehen ein
schuss löste
entscheidend ist aber im prozess ist
auch die erste widerrufene version das
erste geständnis verwertbar und wird
gegen diese neue version stehen
deshalb ist es nie eine kluge
prozessstrategie ein geständnis
abzulegen es zu widerrufen und dann eine
neue version zu präsentieren
taktik oder neue informationen
aufklärung im mordfall lücke wird wohl
erst der prozess bringen
australien brennt und die folgen
bekommen jetzt auch länder auf anderen
kontinenten zu spüren
der rauch hat inzwischen sogar
südamerika erreicht
er zog mehr als 11.000 kilometer über
den pazifik bis an die küste chiles auch
in argentinien sind rauchwolken sichtbar
in australien wüten die feuer seit
oktober mindestens 26 menschen starben
zum sport und zur norbert mit guten
nachrichten von der olympia
qualifikation im volleyball
denn da haben die deutschen frauen nach
dem überraschungserfolg gestern gegen
die türkei heute auch ihr zweites
gruppenspiel gewonnen gegen belgien das
spannende match endete wieder drei zu
eins ein riesenschritt in richtung
halbfinale
ausgelassene deutscher jubel nach einem
hart umkämpften match allein der erste
durchgang dauert nach mehreren
vergebenen satzbällen 37 minuten ehe das
deutsche team gegen starke belgier rinne
mit 1 0 in führung geht trainer felix
koslowski hat seine mannschaft
hervorragend eingestellt und auch der
zweite satz geht nach einem longline
geschlagenen ball von hauptangreiferin
hanna orthmann wieder knapp an das
deutsche team
der dritte durchgang bleibt ausgeglichen
und nach dem deutschland fünf matchbälle
nicht nutzen kann
verwandelt belgien gleich den ersten
satzball unbeeindruckt zieht das
deutsche team im vierten satz bald schon
davon und gewinnt schließlich mit dem
neuen matchball verwandelt von louisa
lippmann
ihr zweites match nacheinander morgen
folgt ein ruhetag am freitag dann das
letzte vorrundenspiel gegen kroatien
morgen beginnt die handball em im ersten
spiel der deutschen mannschaft geht es
in trondheim gegen turnier neuling
niederlande nach platz vier bei der heim
wm vor einem jahr will trainer christian
prokop sein team ein stück weiter nach
oben bringen
am vormittag die erste trainingseinheit
in der nagelneuen halle
die gute nachricht für christian prokop
alle spieler sind fit und einsetzbar
streng genommen sogar einer zu viel
der drb ist mit 17 profis nach norwegen
gereist darf morgen aber nur 16 spieler
einsetzen
deshalb hat der bundestrainer den
flensburger kreisläufer johannes kohler
aus dem kader gestrichen ist eine
taktische entscheidung wir haben drei
kreisläufer zur verfügung mit hendrik
pekeler patrick wiencek und jannik
kohlbacher die gut in form sind
dementsprechend habe ich den schwerpunkt
ein bisschen mehr von nominierung im
rückraum gesucht dieser rückraum kann
sich morgen gleich mal warm werfen denn
der gegner die niederlande ist
allenfalls als zweitklassig einzustufen
das spiel morgen live bei uns im zdf ab
17.45 bierernst und staatstragend so
läuft eigentlich die vereidigung der
regierung in österreich ab für viele
fernsehzuschauer geriet sie gestern
nachmittag allerdings zur komödie durch
die versehentlich eingeblendeten
untertitel einer telenovela
da wurde der jugendliche kanzler kurz
von präsident van der bellen erst als
küken angesprochen
dann bot in der präsident einen job als
putzfrau oder kellner an
darüber lacht ganz österreich ja wenn
das fernsehen solche fehler macht freut
sich der zuschauer wir sind beim lotto
da muss alles stimmen wir kommen die
zahlen
die gewinnzahlen lauten 23 11 25 27 35
und die superzahl 2 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 55
7 das wetter bleibt nass und zu mit für
die jahreszeit mehr dazu gleich von
westen terli das war es von uns danke
für ihr interesse
jetzt folgt das zdf spezial zum iran
konflikt darin auch ein interview mit
außenminister maß morgen ist wieder
barbara hahlweg hier allerdings schon
ein paar minuten vor sieben in der
handball halbzeitpause schönen abend
noch
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter weitere tiefs
erreichen uns von westen her und bringen
viel regen mit sehen es hier in blau und
die fronten überqueren uns einmal über
deutschland und hier kommt sogar warme
luft aus dem südwesten zu uns wenn
dieses tiefe abgezogen ist nähert sich
schon das nächste tief und wir schauen
in die nacht gibt es viele wolken mit
regen aufklaren wird es höchstens im
norden und im süden dort bleibt es auch
trocken mit temperaturen von minus 2
grad im südosten und 10 grad ganz im
westen und das sind die tiefstwerte
morgen im norden viele wolken und regen
der kann auch lang anhaltend sein der
wind weht kräftig aus südwestlichen
richtungen
und auch im süden gibt es regen zwischen
saarland und dem 1
ganz im süden allerdings entlang der
alpen gibt es auch sonnenschein und das
bei temperaturen von sechs grad im
südosten und 14 grad am niederrhein und
im südwesten viel zu mild für die
jahreszeit die nächsten tage am freitag
im norden regen mit stürmischen wind bei
7 bis 12 grad und die darauf folgenden
tage während zwar etwas kühler aber
immer noch zu mild für die jahreszeit
ein schöner abend